60 minuten herzstillstand eigentlich ist
man dann tot
doch in der medizin ist es inzwischen
möglich einen deut langen herzstillstand
unbeschadet zu überleben
das geheimnis ist kälteschlaf und an
dieser stelle werde jetzt einige klicks
und zum jubilieren
denn schon seit geraumer zeit wird
dieses thema gewünscht viele grüße an
den bekennenden alle träger und all die
anderen
das bundle daran der kälteschlaf die
sogenannte hypo termin funktioniert
schon heute und sie wäre die technik die
auch eine reise zum mars deutlich
vereinfachen wird wie weit ist also die
hyperthermie entwickelt können wir damit
jetzt schon astronauten in den
tiefschlaf versetzen das thema in
kriegszeiten fiction herzlich willkommen
in operationssälen ist die hyperthermie
heutzutage keine besonderheit mehr bei
gehirnoperationen oder angriffen anderer
heiz schlagader ist das nichts
ungewöhnliches dabei war die temperatur
des patienten besteuert ganz langsam auf
20 grad celsius abgekühlt also die
körpertemperatur dafür wird das blut aus
dem körper geleitet und in einem dame
überträger auf 15 bis 20 grad abgekühlt
ist dann die temperatur des körpers von
20 grad erreicht wird das herz
angehalten der sauerstoffbedarf das
gehört jetzt nur noch bei 15 prozent des
normalen bedarf es bei körpertemperatur
würde das gehirn nach zwei bis drei
minuten beginnen abzusterben jetzt
überlebt es 60 minuten ohne dabei
schaden zu den operationen in diesem
zustand dauern in der regel 20 bis 30
minuten dann wird das herz wieder
gestartet und der blutkreislauf setzt
wieder ein traum flüge ist dieses
verfahren also nicht geeignet sie dauern
in der regel etwas länger als 60 minuten
je denken wissenschaftler über die milde
hypo termin nach auch wie wird in der
medizin bereits eingesetzt dabei wird
die körpertemperatur nur leicht auf 32
bis 34 grad celsius abgekühlt angewendet
wird diese methode zum beispiel war
patientinnen und patienten die einen
durch kammerflimmern verursachten
herzstillstand hatten jeweils schlägt
das herz nicht mehr sondern es zittert
quasi in einer hohen frequenz und kann
deshalb kein blut mehr transportieren
meistens kann hier ganz schnell mit
einem defibrillator geholfen werden wer
dem herz einen elektroschock verpasst
und es so wieder anwirft
fans von absehen denn das kennen danach
rät das herunterkühlen der
körpertemperatur dazu bei dass die
patienten schneller wieder fit sind und
genau das wäre die technik die auch
ideal für eine mars-mission wäre in der
medizin wird dieser zustand für zwei bis
vier tage aufrechterhalten in
einzelfällen gelang es auch schon vor
zwei wochen bei einem raumflug wäre das
allerdings deutlich länger in
zusammenarbeit mit der nasa entwickelt
die firma space works verfahren wie
milde hypo termin in der raumfahrt
einzusetzen so ist dass dieser verfahren
wie im film passengers zu automatisieren
dabei soll ein teil der crew wach
bleiben und die schlafenden astronauten
und astronautinnen überwachen
sie können so in einen notfall reagieren
der kälteschlaf hätte erhebliche
vorteile für eine mars-mission so würden
nicht nur konflikte innerhalb der crew
familie werden die leicht während einer
langen ereignislosen reise entstehen
könnten auch die nutzlast könnte rund um
die hälfte gesenkt werden
statt 400 tonnen wären es nur 200 tonnen
in diesem tiefschlaf würden auch
deutlich weniger nährstoffe benötigt
werden die der schlafen kann intravenös
zugeführt werden im nächsten jahr will
space box mit den ersten in
tierversuchen beginnen wenn sie
erfolgreich werden erst menschen in den
kelch schlag versetzt und funktioniert
das ohne probleme weil die technik auf
der internationalen raumstation iss
erprobt werden ich hatte euch natürlich
hier auf dem laufenden wollt ihr kein
video zu diesem thema verfassen
dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufsaugen
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke ja und
hier geht es weiter mit der exomars
mission und wie sie außerirdisches leben
auf dem mars finden will das video
startet mit einem klick bis dann bleibt